Plus de 5 ans o que cette Toroa
perdu son fils.
Le jeune homme atteint par balle
à la sortie d'une discothèque
était
réél et elle confie qu'elle
continhercher
de l'aide aujourd'hui .
Cette autre mère torontoise avec
a elle aussi perdu son fils à
cause de la violence armée.
Il a été tué devant leur maison
en 2017.
"Au début, le choc était s mot,
mes aptitudes cognitives ont ét.
Il suffit d'un coup de feu
pour que la vie  ainsi
bouleversée à jamais.
Et en plus des victimes
souvent toute une communauté qui
est ébranlée par une fusillade
et qui en subit le traumatisme,
parfois intergénérationel,
communautaire.
"Or, il manque cruellement de
ces personnes", déplore-t-elle.
C'est aussi le constat de
cette députée provinciale, qui a
déposé un projet de loi privé
de programmes, à la fois en
milieu hospitaliendre
en charge les blessés, mais
aussi en milieu communautaires.
approprié. Elle souhaite que
ces services soient couverent cs
par l'assurance-santé.
"Il s'agit d'une crise de santé
"et c'est de ce point de vue que
vince doit s'y attaquer."
"D'autant plus que personne
n'est à l'abri, aujourdpeut
arriver n'importe où à Toronto"e
ce soit dans un centre achat
ou une fête d'enfant."
"Or, si on abandonne ceux qui
aujourd'hui", dit-il,
au cycle de violence de demain."
Ici Camille Gri